et d'abord donc l'attention aux
frontières de l'ue craignent les
réactions face aux menaces de vladimir
poutine avec mathias à rise
c'est avec un air grave que joe biden
s'est présenté face à la presse ce
mercredi malgré des négociations
ouvertes entre les états unis et la
russie le président américain ne semble
plus écarté la possibilité que les
troupes russes notre en ukraine
le coût d'entrée en ukraine en termes de
pertes de vies humaines pour les russes
ils seront capables de l'emporter mais
ce sera lourd ce soir et elle se sera
lourd de conséquences
une menace également prise au sérieux au
sommet de l'union européenne avec à la
clé une réponse ferme
l'union européenne est de loin le
premier partenaire commercial de la
russie est de loin le premier
investisseur
si la situation se détériore s'il ya de
nouvelles attaques contre l'intégrité
territoriale de l'ukraine nous
répondrons par des sanctions économiques
et financières massives
chance laissée à la marge des
discussions au même titre que
l'allemagne la france a aussi réagi
la souveraineté est une liberté elle est
au coeur de notre projet européen elle
est aussi une réponse aux
déstabilisations à l'oeuvre sur notre
continent c'est pourquoi nous
continuerons avec l'allemagne dans le
cadre du format normandie à rechercher
une solution politique au conflit en
ukraine qui reste le fait générateur des
tensions actuelles
face au stationnement de cent mille
militaires russes aux frontières de
l'ukraine certains pays occidentaux ont
apporté un soutien logistique à kiev le
royaume uni a par exemple envoyé hier
des armes antichars vers la capitale
ukrainienne côté manoeuvre diplomatique
le secrétaire d'état américain anthony
blinken a rencontré le président
ukrainien volodimir zelensky ce vendredi
le chef de la diplomatie américaine sera
à genève avec son homologue russe
sergueï lavrov
pour ce qui est déjà présenté comme un
rendez-vous de la dernière chance
c'est en ukraine on en débat tout de
suite je vous présente mes invités galia
ackerman bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes historienne
spécialiste de la russie vous avez
publié le régiment immortel la guerre
sacrée de poutine c'est aux éditions
premier parallèle général dominique
trinquant dans soient bienvenues ancien
chef de la mission militaire de la
france auprès de l'onu spécialiste des
questions relations internationales
christian ma carrière bonsoir soit vous
êtes journaliste spécialiste vous aussi
de politiques et de questions
internationales et lætitia cru pas
éditorialiste politique bonsoir laetitia
heureux de vous retrouver comme comme
chaque jeudi et chaque mardi on vient
d'entendre les réactions du jour
peut-être pour bien comprendre ce qui se
passe et ce qui est menaces christian
makarian qu'est ce qui prouvait que
cette situation se regardent colère de
vladimir poutine est ce que c'est
l'hypothèse d'une entrée l'ukraine dans
l'otan par exemple
sur ce point il ya eu quand même des
réponses assez claire de la part des
occidentaux et même quand vous prenez
par exemple en ukraine et beaucoup de
déception parmi les décideurs ukrainien
sur le fait que justement il n'y a pas
de processus d'adhésion actuellement
engagés pour que le craignent eux
rejoignent l'otan les calculs de
boutines c'est difficile à évaluer mais
repose sur des choses assez complexes
par exemple le fait que manier une telle
menace aujourd'hui ça lui permet de
tenir la dragée haute aux états unis de
sortir de ce duo qui avait construit bat
edel mais avant lui trump mais aussi
avant trinquent obama c'est à dire
cibler la chine la russie se rappelle au
bon souvenir des états unis si la chine
est un géant économique
la russie reste un pays x existait une
certaine façon dans le conseil
informatique à sa capacité de nuisance
et puis deuxièmement il ya quand même un
abcès très net dans l'est de l'ukraine
dans le dos de masse
il y a deux villes importantes donetsk
est lougansk y sont quand même
peuplé par une majorité de russophones
et cette région est un état de sécession
effective elle échappe complètement
l'autorité de kiev alors après que qui
avait commis des erreurs comme moscou et
des prétentions insupportable tout cela
on peut le dire l'infini mais il y a
préalablement incontestablement une
situation d'irritation avec bien sûr
l'annexion de la crimée en retirer à
l'ukraine en 2014 donc c'était vraiment
le point de départ thiery poutine et
j'ajuste je termine et que sa poutine
c'est que l'otan est en train de
réorganiser sa doctrine en soi même et
qu' il ya une fenêtre de tir pour
exercer sa capacité de nuisance mais
mais on ne peut pas du point de vue
européen ni américains de tolérer que la
russie redéfinissent une zone d'
influence une sphère d'influencé
comme à l'époque de l'union soviétique
galia ackerman ckoi l'ukraine pour la
russie dans l'inconscient collectif
russe
c'est beaucoup plus qu'un territoire
c'est un pays qu'ils ne reconnaissent
pas en tant que pays en tant qu'etat
c'est un peuple qu'ils ne reconnaissent
pas comme un peuple à part c'est à dire
ayant un vieux son fantasme que les
ukrainiens sont des petits frères des
russes que ce sont en fait des russes
qui parlent une langue légèrement
différente voire un dialecte et par
conséquent quand le cren a proclamé son
indépendance en 1991
à l'époque ça convenait parfaitement à
helsinki pensais simplement campe
faisant éclater l'union soviétique il
arriverait lui au pouvoir et c'est
beaucoup plus tard que
les gouvernements russes
pratiquement après l'arrivée de l'ennemi
routine au pouvoir ont compris que le
cren c'est tout à fait sérieux que c'est
un état à part que c'est un peuple à
part qu'il a une autre respiration que
d'être toujours éternellement amis et
petits frères des russes et donc
l'irritation est ancien parce que faut
pas oublier que le cren le territoire de
l'ukraine kiev est une la mère des
villes russes comme disent les russes
que c'est là qu'est né leur taux d'auxi
est donc pour eux c'est le jérusalem qui
est d'une certaine façon c'est presque
une parenthèse qui voudraient refaire
mais si je parle très historique
poutine a écrit un article cet été oui
dit qu'en fait voilà il nie
l'existence du cren indépendante en tant
qu'etat et d'ukrainiens en tant que
peuple c'est vous savez l'argument comme
quoi l'ukraine n'a jamais eu d'état
quand quelque sorte c'est l'union
soviétique lénine qui lui a donné un
statut de république fédérée et donc une
existence étatique certes restreinte
mais c'est un argument en fait est
recevable parce que il ya plein de
peuples comme les kurdes comme les
palestiniens comme tant d'autres
saharouis et les berbères les kabyles et
setra qui n'ont pas d'état mais qui sont
quand même des entités constitué et
certains de ces peuples arrive à accéder
à un état comme ça s'est passé avec
plusieurs pays de l'afrique et d'autres
pas encore mais cela une fois que
l'indépendance est proclamée c'est c'est
en fait c'est passionnant parce que ça
permet vraiment de d'éclairer ce qui est
en train de se passer et je voudrais
avec vous général de 8,5 en comprendre
justement peut-être militairement parce
que moi ce qui m'a fait tiquer ce matin
et donner envie d'ouvrir ce débat c'est
un article de ouest france qui parlait
de ses si je disais bruits de bottes
lis aussi quoi ces six navires de
débarquement la key qui était au large
de de la manche alors son coin
vraisemblablement route vers la mer
noire c'est ça on a en a trouvé la carte
où on voit le trajet qui pourrait te
sens de faire ce qu'on appelle le
véhicule des forces en logistique ces
bateaux il y en a quand même pas des
milliers donc si on a besoin de bateau
de débarquement se trouve qu'ils étaient
dans les ports dans la baltique et il
faut les basculer vers la mer noire vers
le sud je rappelle que l'intérêt aussi
de l'ukraine pour la russie en
particulier lors de la prise de la
crimée c'est le port de sébastopol c'est
l'accès aux mers chaudes qui a toujours
été un peu un sujet pour les russes
faudrait souligner simplement que dans
cette crise il ya deux effets qu'il faut
pas oublier le premier c'est que poutine
a évacué les européens ils discutent
directement hebeisen mon avis c'est une
faute des américains ils ont
poti a réussi à revenir au niveau auquel
il voulait être on parle de seul à seul
avec les américains comprenez mais le
format normandie minsk les français et
les allemands ça nous intéresse pas nous
on est une grande puissance on discute
directeur avec les américains donc ça
c'est la première fois la deuxième fois
et pourquoi les relais américains jouent
ce rôle là il faut pas oublier qu'on est
pas très loin de kaboul ils ont quand
même quelques erreurs à faire oublier
auprès des européens rappelé que le
temps c'est la puissance l'otan c'est ce
qui va permettre de défendre des pays
laisse juste après kaboul souvenez-vous
de de là
la rage des européens qui disent on
n'était même pas dans le coup et j'ai
américains font n'importe quoi on n'est
pas dans le coup décide d'évacuer donc
le temps avec un sacré cran sans
concertation voilà autant avait pris un
sacré coup et là on peut replacer l'otan
dans la position de défense deux
européens il ya un sujet qui est très
très intéressant dans le discours du
président macron hier c'est que on avait
réussi après plusieurs années à amener
les pays européens à regarder vers le
sud vers le sahel et là on n'en a pas
parlé du tout et on est revenu à
l'ukraine et à l'est et la menace
majeure dans les pays de l'est européen
alors justement laetitia ça va être
intéressant de voir comment emmanuel
macron finalement ce se place c'était à
l'occasion de son discours effectivement
hier
devant le parlement européen il doit
prouver que sa voix compte dans les
crises internationales mais c'est
intéressant quand vous parlez de l'otan
parce que je vous rappelle le mot du
président à propos de l'otan état de
mort cérébrale donc alors merci monsieur
poutine aujourd'hui il faudrait faire
appel à l'otan envoyez donc c'est
compliqué quand même emmanuel macron et
joue une carte vis-à-vis de l'opinion
publique française parce qu'évidemment
on en sort on est à quoi moins de trois
mois du premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle et donc il sait bien que
c'est une carte qu'il a à jouer pour
finalement
et éloigner ses adversaires et puis
après quand c'est non c'est pas dans les
sciences à son sommet des préoccupations
des français c'est quasi normal en génie
français sont préoccupés par le pouvoir
d'achat et la santé mais ce sujet de
l'international de la stature
internationale il compose de façon forte
et fondamentale l'image d'un candidat à
l'élection présidentielle et ça emmanuel
macron et le sait pertinemment pour deux
raisons parce que dès son arrivée à
l'elysée il a travaillé cette stature
pourquoi parce qu'il était inconnu des
français et donc ils devaient ils
devaient montrer qu'il était crédible et
légitime --donc il a choisi d'être ce
leader européen qu'il est aujourd'hui
finalement donc si vous voulez il a
enfin incarner le rôle il al'occasion de
l'incarner le rose qui s'était donné et
2017 et là où il ya une carte à jouer
c'est que par exemple marine le pen dans
toutes les enquêtes d'opinion m6 elle
remonte dans les items plutôt positif
comme l'humanité comme plus proche des
gens le côté présidentiable elle ne l'a
toujours pas jean luc mélenchon aussi
l'opinion publique lui reprochent son
manque de présidentialité et donc
emmanuel macron c'est qu'il a cette
carte à jouer et il envoie comme
d'habitude ses lieutenants parler un peu
pour lui préparer le terrain écouter par
exemple clément bonne il était sur
france info mardi matin et vous
comprendrez comme ça en filigrane le
personnage qu emmanuel macron va nous
présenter bientôt quand les russes tease
c'est à nous de décider qui rentre ou
pas dans l'otan ce n'est pas aux russes
ou de menacer un pays européen proche de
nous et ce n'est pas aux russes
évidemment les décider ce qu'est notre
alliance l'otan l'occurrence donc nous
serons extrêmement fermes sur ce point
ça n'exclut pas on l'a parfois reprocher
nous l'assumons pour la république
l'assument d'avoir un dialogue aussi
difficile soit il parfois aussi bouché
souhaite-il avec vladimir poutine parce
que notre but n'est pas d'être va-t-en
guerre mais notre but est de nous
défendre d'envoyer un signal très clair
et de dire aux que ce n'est pas eux qui
définissent fortiori sans les européens
ce qui se passe en europe et l'atteinte
à un pays donc vous l'avez vu vous le
disiez c'est vrai attrait sont très
justes les russes finalement se mettent
à la même hauteur que les états unis
emmanuel macron lui dans son discours se
met à la même hauteur que la russie que
vladimir poutine or nous savons tous que
finalement bon la puissance de la france
dans ce jeu diplomatique et le levier
d'action cas là et quand même minime
voire nuls 1 pour reprendre l'état de
mort cérébrale emmanuel macron le sait
il est en train de compter les points et
d'essayer de rentrer tant bien que mal
dans les daims dans les discussions par
une porte comme à rien d'autre et ses
adversaires aussi savent que c'est
peut-être un des petits défauts qui
pourraient apparaître et donc marine le
pen n'arrête pas dire qu'effectivement
il n'est que spectateur et que tout se
joue entre la russie et les etats unis
ce qui est vrai factuellement est alors
pour ce qui est par exemple de jean luc
mélenchon lui dis carrément mais vous
les envoyer nos troupes en ukraine alors
qu'on n' est pas du tout à ce stade là
et moi répond t-il non je ne veux pas
donc vous voyez que cette question
internationale bien qu'elle ne soit pas
dans les préoccupations premières des
français reste fondamentale épaisse quoi
la voie d'un président français tient
sur vous regardez beaucoup les télés
russes en ce moment oui est ce que est
ce qu'on voit souvent le visage des
manuels macrohori ce que je veux dire
est ce que ça peut peser la voix de la
france non sauf dans des reportages
totalement ridicule comme par exemple la
télé russe a fait tout un truc autour
d'un
d'une fausse information en fait
répondu par l'extrême droite comme quoi
brigitte macron aurait été un tranchant
oui non vraiment dans le délire voilà on
voit le visage du matin mais quand il
fait un discours au parlement européen
non non non absolument pas donc en
général c'était vrai pour la première
élection de manuel macron c'est vrai
aujourd'hui aussi il ya beaucoup de
haine de diriger bruce pour emmanuel
macron ce qui est un bon signe ce qui
est un bon signe ça veut dire comptage
final exactement non mais il faut voir
l' inverse si vous voulez dans le
discours dont on parle rapports avec la
russie l'otan vous citiez tout à l'heure
madame le pen monsieur zemmour monsieur
mélenchon ils ont une vision très
opposée et qui aujourd'hui va avoir
quelques mal à progresser je pense à ils
font quitter l'otan il faut opposer de
nous mêmes comment peut-on peser nous
même si l'on n'est pas à l'intérieur de
l'otan dans cette configuration c'est
extrêmement difficile il faut être plus
qu'à miami avec monsieur poutine
regardez c'est quand même lui qui pousse
les feux c'est pas nous qui pousse les
feux mais bon quel à l'injection de
l'otan en fait finalement dans une
géopolitique maintenant qui se joue
d'état et à d'état ^ ^ est ce que l'otan
encore une efficacité mais les
américains sont puissants face à la
russie dans l'ukraine parce qu'il y à
l'otan une file était seul il ne serait
pas puissant aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui
se passe ce sont les pays baltes qui
envoient des armes des javelin anti tank
avec l'autorisation des américains à
l'ukraine c'est bien l'otan vous voyez
c'est cette articulation sansan l'otan
les états unis en europe ne pèsent rien
mais sont les etats-unis le temps ne
faisons rien fait ça c'est évidemment
totalement liés christian makarian
revient sur la déclaration de là
prison de la commission européenne on en
a vu un extrait dans le reportage tout à
l'heure ursula von der leyen quand elle
dit cette relation elle parle évidemment
de l'europe et de la russie premier
partenaire commercial de la russie cette
relation commerciale est importante pour
nous elle est beaucoup plus importante
pour la russie donc là on est quoi dans
une menace voilée de sanctions
économiques c'est ça alors le catalogue
des sanctions a été explorée il a été
même exposer clairement vie par les
américains il ya une sanction qui est
vraiment efficace et qui est très
technique mais qu'il faut quand même
citer c'est de stopper de d'arrêter le
système swift le système de transactions
interbancaires c'est à dire que plus
rien de financiers ne passerai ne
sortirait de la rue fini n'entrera
russie s'y enfermer ce robinet là c'est
celui qui permet de payer tous y compris
les matières premières mais en dehors de
cela toutes les sanctions qui ont été
prises jusqu'ici ont été contournées par
la russie parce que vladimir poutine
tout simplement dispose d'un pays dans
lequel son taux de popularité même s'il
a baissé reste très élevé dans lequel il
n'ya pas d'opinion publique constitué
dans lequel il a été écrêtée toute forme
d'opposition regarder le sort réservé à
ce mouvement navalni donc la lumière
poutine utilise au maximum
en ce moment il ya un momento pop-up
poutine clairement qui est encore une
fois je répète ce que je disais tout à
l'heure l'otan est en train de re
envisager sa doctrine après les attaques
du président français mais c'était pas
le seul et les critiques d'autres chefs
d'état
l'otan est est un peu affaissé c'est le
moment a jugé poutine dans ses calculs
assez méchant fondamentalement c'est le
moment d'agir pour me démontrer la force
de la russie mais je crois qu'il faut
rappeler un certain nombre de choses sur
l'ukraine bon d'abord c'est un pays qui
a été occupée par les français au début
des années 20 tout de suite après la
première mondiale après la révolution
bolchévique les français les anglais ça
ne leur plaisait pas de voir la russie
devenir bolchévique il ya eu des
nationalistes ukrainiens qui se sont
soulevés et c'est même nationalistes
ukrainiens étaient ensuite écrasé par
staline qui a organisé une famine géante
quelque chose d'absolument bas
abominable les rapports entre la russie
et l'ukraine ne sont pas linéaires ni
fluide et enfin je crois que vous serez
d'accord gaia même si la russie
kiévienne effectivement n'est
historiquement
en ukraine et précisément à kiev mais il
y a tout de même autre chose qu'il faut
rappeler lorsque l'ukraine est devenue
indépendante en 1991
c'était le troisième état nucléarisé du
monde et oui et sans l'oubli ces terres
qui avait un arsenal installé par les
russes à l'époque soviétique sur le
territoire ukrainien gigantesque qui
fait que ça a beaucoup compté dans le
débat à une énonciation voilà dans les
négociations donc si vous voulez ils
étaient d'autant plus difficiles à
l'otan d'avancé dans cette zone là que
c'était si j'ose dire ultra sensible
pour les russes et puis toujours
aujourd'hui c'est une zone très sensible
dans le dos de basses étaient fabriqués
jusqu'au début de la crise ukrainienne
80% des moteurs d'hélicoptères
russes et oui les assemblages se faisait
peut-être ailleurs mais les pièces
étaient fabriqués là plus de 90% du
matériel ferroviaire et qui avait plus
de chemin de fer si la russie perdait
cette région entre guillemets bon enfin
bref il ya des il ya une argumentation
russe souvent fallacieuses et
mensongères
mais enfin il ya il ya des arguments
alors pour finir de répondre à votre
question
l'ukraine représente quelque chose
d'absolument essentiel puisque par
ailleurs c'est un pays qui aspire à se
rapprocher de l'union européenne et qui
échange beaucoup avec l'union européenne
et qui a un voisinage qui est totalement
de l'union européenne
c'est un enjeu d'ancrage quel côté
l'ukraine la pensée la pologne est déjà
menacée au maire d'hasparren discouru ce
récurrent le fait que en doivent une
solidarité à tous ces pays d'europe
centrale qui ont peur objectivement
c'est quelque chose que poutine connais
par coeur et ils manipulent cette crise
pour démontrer aussi la faiblesse
endémique de l'union européenne sur
l'absence de forces armées sur l'absence
de politiques alliées ackermann il ya
une sorte d'ultimatum une série
d'ultimatums posée par poutine aux
occidentaux c'est ça avec ce ce traité
sur la sécurité en europe oui parce que
je suis traité avec il peut en traiter
avec l'otan et un traité avec les états
unis et c'est un ultimatum même avec la
meilleure volonté du monde même si on
voulait céder sur certains points il a
été dit non on s'est pas que vous pouvez
choisir ceci et cela c'est un bloc toho
rien et donc les exigences sont
absolument impossible encore c'est à
dire ce que veut la russie s'est pas
seulement qu'il n'y ait plus d'armements
étrangers en ukraine ni deux
de
d'instructeurs ni que jamais le cren
adhère à l'otan et setra ce qu'ils
veulent c'est d'une part que le cren
reste totalement désarmé mais d'autre
part que l'otan en quelque sorte face
rejeté tous les membres de l'otan
c'est-à-dire la moitié de l'europe qui
ont adhéré à partir de 1997 quand il ya
eu la première vague d'adhésion à l'otan
ça c'est quelque chose d'impossible à un
conflit et pour les etats unis ils
veulent que les états unis ramène tout
leur
toutes leurs installations
militaires aux etats-unis il n'y a plus
d'un moment américain en europe donc
tout ça est impossible tout ça tombe
bien haut possible déjà cette semaine
on est jeudi je crois ils veulent les
réponses écrites pour chaque fois
si vous voulez sans rentrer dans le
détail en méthode de négociation c'est
nul et non avenu et y la rencontre de
demain entre monsieur blinken et
monsieur lavrov je rappelle que le
monsieur lavrov qui se trouve que j'ai
connu à new york n'a été ambassadeur
s'étend à new york un grand diplomate
c'est très bien qu'on n'arrive pas avec
celles de lannion de massy ruiz voilà
depuis longtemps inquiets qui est
remarquable il sait très bien qu'on
n'arrive pas une négociation avec une
feuille en disant vous signez là où l'on
s'affaire
à mon avis justement c'est là où la
posture est difficile parce qu'il sait
très bien et monsieur blinken l'a déjà
dit il a dit on ne signera pas voilà
viendra pas sûr vérifier donc c'est ça
c'est la position vis-à-vis de la russie
et vis-à-vis de ses alliés c'est à dire
moi je suis ferme je suis fort je
présente des propositions et en face on
ne me propose rien oui mais quelle est
la réponse si on ne me propose rien et
c'est là la difficulté où il peut se
mettre dans un entonnoir en disant
écoutez on nous a tous refusé qu'est ce
qu'on fait on s'en va c'est pas possible
donc c'est là où ça va être intéressant
de voir ce que monsieur blinken peut
proposer lui il faut qu'ils se lèvent au
niveau stratégique en disant qu'on des
problèmes majeurs par exemple les
missiles la problème des missiles vous
savez que les accords sur les missiles
n'existe plus en europe puisque les
russes comme les américains ont arrêté
de les négocier à leur échéance donc là
il ya des vrais sujets qu'il faut amener
sur la table donc on va voir là la
finesse de la diplomatie américaine si
elle arrive à amener les russes sur une
vraie position de négociation et non pas
sur ses ultimatums qui sont nuls et non
avenus mais il ya combien d'hommes
m'asséner deux côtés de la frontière en
dit quoi sans mines côté
côté russe et 150000 côté ukrainien
c'est ça ça je ne sais pas br permettez
moi de vous dire que la guerre a déjà
commencé les petits hommes verts qui
avaient en crimée sont forcément
également présents actuellement dans le
combat et donc donc là c'était quoi
s'était dépêché mercenaires des
auditoires us simplement
c'est pour ça qu'on les aime fait des
petits hommes verts parce qu'ils
n'étaient pas identifiables dons qui
seront probablement présent donc la
frontière ukrainienne a été franchie la
difficulté la différence c'est quand ils
viendront avec des drapeaux russe la
safra une vraie différence mais le deux
enfants parlent du scénario de
l'incident à la frontière où ils ont
bien ce que ça va c'est la planète quoi
ces incidents et long terme et long
terme d'un incident qui a eu cet avion
n'est là malgré qui a été abattu par des
missiles dont tout le monde sait c'était
un missile russe qui a été mis dans les
dents les dents dans les mains des
rebelles mais des rebelles mais la
guerre a déjà commencé en cyber le
week-end dernier il ya eu de grosses
attaques cyber donc la russie essaie
avec la crimée mais bien sûr mais là
c'est la russie est familière de ces
mouvements là le micro pour pousser un
petit peu tout les les limites et savoir
jusqu'où on peut aller et je juste pour
l'anecdote nous sommes sur la frontière
est de l'ukraine sur la frontière ouest
il ya ce qu'on appelle la transnistrie
entre la moldavie et la russie ça fait
est là l ukraine parlant ça fait trente
ans maintenant que cette zone est une
zone de non droit reconnue uniquement
par la russie et qui permet aux idoles
esi requis ya des conflits gelés et est
ce que l'ukraine l'est de l'ukraine
resteras un conflit gelé c'est à dire un
abcès de fixation qui servira la russie
c'est possible moi je ferai pas de
supputations mais il ya des conflits
gelés il ya aussi une instabilité
organiser une instabilité syndicaux les
jeux voilà c'est ça c'est son talent à
quoi la pelle confie gelées sont pas
toujours mais regardez ce qui s'est
passé depuis quelques années ont bien
sûr l'ukraine mais avant ça il ya la
géorgie en 2008 que la russie a corrigé
et lui a infligé une correction en lui
retirant deux régions historiques
voilà deux morceaux du territoire c'est
une amputation pour la géorgie l'an
dernier seulement en octobre en eau en
septembre 2020 l'azerbaïdjan à tech et
l'arménie la russie s'est proposé comme
force d'interposition avec peu de monde
et moi ce qui me frappe c'est que la
russie avec peu d'investissement parce
que ça reste une puissance pauvres peu
d'investissements militaires cinq mille
cinq cents hommes en syrie deux mille
hommes il ya quinze jours au kazakhstan
et encore certains n'étaient pas russie
promener de l'hôtesse et l'organisation
du traité de sécurité collective qui est
une espèce de pendant celui de l'otan
mais complètement raté mes moyens de
dans le kazakhstan le kirghizstan le
disque avec peu d'hommes ici ça mais peu
d'hommes au kazakhstan très peu d'hommes
en arménie pour arrêter le conflit face
à l'azerbaïdjan et peu d'hommes
également
en syrie donc je sais c'est pas du tout
énormes et ils contrôlent toute la syrie
mais je sur quoi ça veut dire qu'on joue
sur des croyances sur des peurs
sur la communication la en jour sur le
fait qu'à une doctrine poutine dans sa
tête à lui qui marche qui fonctionne
c'est ça qui est dangereux c'est que il
peut très vite et il est difficile comme
l'expliqué général trinquant mais aussi
gaillac amman il est difficile d'arrêter
un engrenage quand vous l'avez lancé or
cet engrenage qui consiste à faire une
inflation verbales et des gestes à la
clé est assorti d'une théorie très
fréquente au kremlin où on est convaincu
que l'amérique est en déclin
voilà déconstruire oui mais alors c'est
intéressant parce que c'est une question
de sensibilité
c'est une question de limur poutine il
faudrait qu'ils affichent une sorte de
reculades quoi si je vous comprends la
maison que c'est difficile comme dans
les films de james bond de m une barre
de fer quand les gars bien
ackermann comment ça se passe comment
est-ce que vladimir poutine prépare même
si effectivement les oppositions était
cramé mais est-ce qui prépare malgré
tout l'opinion russe à un conflit ils
préparent l'opinion russe et il fait
militariser la société russe depuis des
années ce que j'ai écrit il ya trois ans
dans le livre que vous avez cité le
régiment est mortel s'était déjà en
pleine construction et si je publier ce
livre maintenant j'aurais pu encore
acheter des exemples mais sur le fond
c'était déjà en 2019 cette société est
constamment préparer à la guerre et mais
est ce que cela est encore plus vrai
depuis quelques jours à metz etc etc
c'est plus vrai avec chaque jour qui
passe quand je regarde par exemple des
débats à la télé russe ou même des
émissions des journaux télévisés et on
parle tout le temps d'une grande guerre
parce que il faut quand même comprendre
une chose il ya deux scenarii possibles
pourquoi est-ce que poutine lance des
ultimatums qui d'emblée sont impossibles
à
faire respecter enfin
il ya deux solutions soit il met la
barre très haut pour pouvoir descendre
et dire ok ok pour les rebelless ça va
mais je vous prendrai l'ukraine ça c'est
encore le scénario optimiste
optimiste il ya pire que ça il ya dire
que ça parce que
il pense peut-être outils que maintenant
il ya encore une fenêtre de possibilités
comme ça à était déjà dit parce que ils
sont plusieurs armements innovant qui
parfois
n'ont même pas d'équivalent dans dans
les armements occidentaux à moins que ce
soit du bluff je ne sais pas le messie
ni
ici la vendée
est arrivé et
est donc il faut le faire matt
maintenant parce que deux ans et demi ce
sera de la plus tard ce sera trop tard
j'entends encore et il ya encore une
hypothèse c'est que il ya certaines
rumeurs on ne peut pas savoir si c'est
vrai ou non que petit des malades et
donc peut-être s'il veut accomplir le
rêve messianique
retrouver la puissance de l'union
soviétique
peut-être qu'il ne lui reste plus
beaucoup de temps et ça c'est
l'hypothèse la preuve ici là on a une
preuve de sa est bon ça fait partie des
des rumeurs vous qui être en prise avec
la russie c'est intéressant nous nous
dire ça côté ukrainien cesser
merrick c'est l'otan qui arme il ya eu
beaucoup d'argent beaucoup de matériel
10e et l'armement de la formation qui a
été donné on appuie bien sûr de
l'ukraine je crois que ce qui est
intéressant aussi voir c'est que la
montée en puissance de l'armée russe
avec les exercices que vous avez bien
démontré les opérations très bien
démontré date des années 2000 quand
monsieur poutine est arrivé l'incident
du course que tout le monde ce dont on
ne se souvient elle était une
catastrophe il a mis beaucoup d'argent
il a modernisé il a professionnalisé
l'armée ça fait vingt ans ça correspond
à quoi ça correspond au contraire chez
nous à ce qu'on appelait les dividendes
de la paix c'est à dire que nous pendant
20 ans on a dit ça y est la pépite
éternelle il ya plus un de s'armer et
puis en 2015 à peu près donc quinze ans
après poutine on s'est dit il ya une
menace essentiellement islamistes et on
a commencé à réarmer et donc l'europe
vous avez raison et l'otan est en retard
par rapport à la russie sur le
réarmement avec en particulier bien sûr
les armements
très moderne donc je pense que là il ya
effectivement pour lui une opportunité
de montrer qu'il est au point qu'il est
capable de grimper et que nous ne sommes
pas capables de grimper au même niveau
que lui alors qui veut faire la guerre
pour l'ukraine vous vous l'avez évoqué
tout à l'heure on va écouter jean luc
mélenchon sa réponse elle est très
claire le candidat de la france est
soumise
le mode horde pour moi si j'ai exercé la
présidence française ce serait la
désescalade la désescalade le retrait
des instruments de guerre qui ont été
déployés aussi bien sur la frontière de
la russie directement que ceux qui ont
été déployés en pologne avec les
batteries de missiles antimissiles rien
de bon ne viendrait et certainement pas
des gesticulations du président de l'ong
dit quand il a dit qu'il avait
l'intention de préserver l'intégrité
physique de l'ukraine comme s'il était
acquis que cette intégrité été mis en
cause et que à ce moment là nous aurions
à réagir si les mots ont un sens madame
c'est d'une gravité extrême je pense
qu'on pourrait en parler quand même au
moins une fois au parlement français les
français sont ils prêts à entrer en
guerre pour protéger les frontières
actuelles de l'ukraine ne s'est pas
bouka
mais son macaron ça vous fait réagir oui
il ya des inexactitudes à propos de
l'invité et la gravité s'est elle tient
plutôt propos qu'on vient d'entendre
parce que jean luc mélenchon faut le
rappeler soutient le régime du venezuela
qui aboutit à la famine et l exode du
peuple vénézuélien
il soutient le régime de cuba et il
soutient la russie en toutes
circonstances possibles on se demande
presque hélas ces fausses on se demande
pourquoi il dit qu'il y à des armements
masser par les européens aux frontières
de la russie c'est faux
une propagande russe on l'entend
beaucoup à la télévision solide dit
qu'il ya des missiles nucléaires de
l'otan pointé sur la sur la russie c'est
faux c'est tout à fait faux et si vous
allez en ukraine encore une fois vous
entendrez les gens se plaindre et même
pleuré parce que ils n'ont pas assez
reçu d'armement et que on fait très
attention du côté de l'otan à ne pas
provoquer la russie jusque là russie
n'attend que cela donc on va pas lui
fournir ce prétexte même lorsque la
turquie de monsieur herman décide
d'aider l'ukraine pour retourner en
grâce auprès des américains eh bien elle
fait très attention au matériel qui est
l'envoi en ukraine ce sont des drôles
principalement mais les russes aussi en
les leurs donc non ce que dit monsieur
mêlant chant est faux il n'y a pas de
menace ou audi par l'otan contre la
russie ni de massification d'armement de
la part de l'otan aux frontières de
l'art jce vrai j'ai d'entrer en guerre
pour la france pour aller défendre les
frontières et la dernière phrase là on
voit bien ce qu'ils agitaient alors
c'est intéressant parce qu'on peut
élargir on va terminer là dessus il nous
reste quelques minutes à la question
américaine a quand même peut parler des
américains et de joe biden dominique
train quand c'est vrai que
il avait semblé ambigu le président
américain dans une réponse évoquant une
incursion mineurs de la russie comme
s'il n'était pas trop grave et la maison
blanche a dû vendre à communiquer dans
la foulée en dix ans dix ans en menaçant
d'une réponse je cite un rapide sévère
et uni des états unis et de deux alliés
en cas en cas d'incursion bien sûr parce
que je pense que monsieur baden à
exprimer ce qu'on lui avait exprimé dans
les analyses les analyses militaires sur
qu'est ce que peuvent faire les russes
attaqués jusqu'à kiev faire une ce qu'on
appelle une prise de gage c'est à dire
le donbass
solidifier ce truc là il y avait
différentes hypothèses et dans les
hypothèses celle là qui était le plus
une des hypothèses la plus basse oui
donc des incursions il a vu revenir à un
coeur sur mineur voilà on va pas y aller
il a eu tort de le dire mais qu'à partir
du moment où vous marquez la ligne qu'on
peut franchir et qu'on peuvent pas
franchir vous tendez forcément la main à
celui qui va le faire et donc il est il
a eu tort de l'exprimer comme ça il faut
avoir une expression extrêmement ferme
même si les russes savent très très bien
joué là dessus je parlais des petits
hommes verts qui sont sûrement dans le
donbass les gens qui sont en crimée et
il va falloir voir jusqu'où ils vont
dans ce dans ce jeu là ajoutons que
monsieur poutine était en très bons
termes avec donald trump le bret
nécessaire ben est l'ennemi des joe
biden et que voir joe biden se prendre
les pieds dans le tapis de cette façon
là ça ne peut que réjouir les russes
vous souvenez qui avait quand même la
menace de monsieur tron qui disaient oui
il fallait que les ukrainiens arrive à
donner les dossiers du fils de monsieur
parizeau qui avait travaillé bien sûr
désarmement du crème mais christian ma
carrière on peut terminer là dessus il
ya quand même une continue de lever un
peu évoqué tout à l'heure mais quand
même une continuité de la politique
extérieure américaine depuis obama en
passant par donald trump qui est à quai
à une sorte de repli sur soi même oui
mais paradoxalement un joe biden qui a
été à la commission des affaires
étrangères du sénat pendant de très
nombreuses années et tonnes d homme qui
connaît le mieux la russie parmi les
décideurs américains lui il la connaît
vraiment donc c'est au nom de voir
qu'ils soient aussi maladroit parce que
je crois tout simplement que ça se
heurte à la doctrine générale non pas du
repli américain mais de la
reconcentration des forces américaines
sur ses objectifs ciblés plutôt que
d'être gens des raisons en éventail à
travers le monde et que cette
translation de doctrine aux états unis
entre un pays qu est partout présent est
un pays qui sera présent de manière
décisive dans certains lieux qu'il aura
choisi certains terrains qu'il aura
choisi cette translation elle est mal
faite par joe biden qui quelque part est
un homme de l'ancienne période et ça se
sent c'est là que poutine
malheureusement a encore un peu de marge
de manoeuvre et je pense qu'il faut
encore une fois craindre comme la digue
à craindre toutes sortes de scénarios et
rester extrêmement vigilant en tout cas
en tant qu il un on peut pas sortir du
décor comme
l'impression dominante le montre
aujourd'hui il faut que les européens
d'une manière ou d'une autre reviennent
dans le jeu et s'impose comme partenaire
exigeant vis-à-vis de la russie merci
beaucoup merci à tous merci à tous les
trois d'avoir participé à ce débat galia
ackerman rappel le titre de votre livre
le régiment immortel la guerre sacrée de
poutine c'est aux éditions
premier parallèle